ja leute das ist doch perfekt stellt
euch mal vor ihr lehrer in der schule
liege später euren garten baut geht zu
weiter schule
hey leute was knapp und herzlich
willkommen beim ein video welches offene
stelle ich euch geht's gut
heute gestern wie ich mache mal kurz
noch einen heller oder wartet die
gebühren die belichtung gefällt mir
nicht gehört ja so ist gut auf jeden
fall kam er gestern noch mal ein video
wo ich davor ihre zeugnisse reagiert
habt ihr euch mir angeschaut habe ich
bewertet so alt wie ich davor auch schon
mal gemacht habe und es war echt witzig
und das machen wir auch eine menge spaß
eigentlich habe ich heute gesagt der
alex heute kannst du kein video machen
weil ich wirklich noch lernen muss aber
ich habe ein bisschen die kommentare
gelesen unter dem letzten video also das
von gestern das ist doch echt mega gut
angekommen hat dank an dieser stelle und
einer der top kommentare war yandex
reagiert doch bitte mal auf einem balkon
schule zeugnis des haben wirklich sehr
sehr viele auch in den kommentaren
geschrieben dass ich mir das mal
anschauen sondern durch werden soll
wobei ich das auch schon mal so ein ganz
bisschen also ein ganz kleinen auslass
um zeugnis hatte ich auch schon mal in
einem der videos nur so ein ganzes
zeugnis halt nicht und ich wusste ja
dass ich noch einige auflage hab also
die hat mich wirklich zugewandt auf
instagram mit zeit wissen wenn wir
vergeben nicht folgt mir kurz fünf
sekunden zeit
ich glaube dass man jetzt sogar sieben
sekunden
deswegen habe ich mich jetzt ganz
spontan hingesetzt hat mir noch mal eben
meinen waldorfschulen zeugnis
rausgekramt von jemandem von euch ich
weiß nicht ob der name jeden im begriff
ist kann auch sein dass das irgendwo in
deutschland oder österreich oder schweiz
anders heißt also dass man den begriff
waldorfschule nicht kennt falls das so
ist das ist halt an sich natürlich auch
eine normale schule nur viele haben als
so vorteile so die tanzenden namen und
keine ahnung gehe halt irgendwie ein
bisschen anders mit dem begriff lernen
um da gibt es auch keine normalen
zeugnisse mit noten sondern halt einfach
so texte da steht dann halt drin ja die
schülerin macht das und das gut oder der
schüler der wir schauen erst mal rein
ich bin auch echt interessiert weil ich
kann mir gar nicht so wirklich
vorstellen was da genau drin steht und
ich werde viele von euch geht es
sicherlich genauso also
ja ich will gar nicht eingeladen wir
sind gespannt also ich habe rausbekommen
dass deswegen die typische solche
zeugnisse ist weil da erst mal so eine
einführung steht und dann hat jeder
irgendwie so ein zeugnis spruch oder so
ein lieblingsspruch davor also jetzt zum
beispiel mal der spur von aurelia auch
er zeigte sich im siebten schuljahr
hindurch als eine sehr vielseitige
interessierte schülerinnen
sie ist im unterricht eine zumeist
aufmerksam und einfühlsame zu hören was
ich immer wieder auch darin zeigt dass
die frage gestellt oder auch beantwortet
blablabla so geht das halt weiter das
ist ähnlich so wie man das aus der
grundschule kennen also erst wieder
zweiter klasse sondern habe ich jetzt
von jemandem der schon etwas älter ist
so ein waldorfschulen zeugnis bekommen
um stets über das war die neunte klasse
die person ist jetzt allerdings von
glaube ich in der zehnten klasse oder
ich verwechsle das jetzt ich weiß es
nicht mehr genau auf jeden fall sind das
dann laufen also zettel wir jetzt zum
beispiel wir oben drüber steht das fach
also deutsch in diesem fall und dann
steht da halt so ein riesen langer text
wie man halt im unterricht bei also ich
würd sagen jetzt schauen wir uns jetzt
mal an ich glaube genau sie hatte ich
auch schon mal in meiner videos ich habe
doch schon teil genannt weil man den
namen ich sehen könnte deswegen stand
halt so wir schauen und skandale in
deutschland zwar manchmal abgelenkt
durch intensive gespräche mit der
tischnachbarin aha war chantal jedoch
meist aufmerksam und mit interesse bei
der sache immer wieder meldete sie sich
mit fundierten und durchdachten
beiträgen zu wort und bereicherte das
unterrichts gespräch also zu deutsch
eigentlich nur positive rückmeldungen
stadtteil war mit interesse und
engagement bei der sache wieso ist denn
da unten jetzt nochmal deutsches zweimal
deutsch sie hörte gut zu brachte sich
öfteren mit eigenständigen überlegungen
im unterrichts gespräch ein und so
weiter also das sind ja eigentlich nur
positive rückmeldungen
das wollen wir hier ja eigentlich gar
nicht hören denn wir wollen ja was
witziges am besten möglichst schlecht
ist weil das verspricht die meisten das
war auch einer der top kommentare unter
dem video von gestern
alex diese videos sind so toll da merkt
man richtig dass man nicht der
schlechteste ist und es immer noch
welche gibt die noch schlechter sind
gerne
deswegen würde ich sagen wir gehen jetzt
einfach mal zu machen blickt man auf das
gesamte schuljahr zurück so sieht man
dass die arbeitsergebnisse von chantal
recht konstant ausfielen und im oberen
zufriedenstellenden bereich lagen sie
nach einem
mit großer aufmerksamkeit gab aber
leider nur wenige mündliche beiträge zum
klassen gespräch erwischt in der zehnten
klasse sollen sie versuchen sich öfters
zu melden
die hausaufgaben macht sie mit
regelmäßigkeit wie bei mir eigentlich
mal macht man die unwahrheit nicht also
ich muss sagen ich hab auch so eine zeit
habe ich die echt selten gemacht bei uns
war das nicht immer so die lehrer fragen
ja dann am anfang hat irgendwer die
hausaufgaben nicht gemacht und dann kann
man ja versuchen einfach nicht zu sagen
auch wenn man die hausaufgaben gar nicht
gemacht hat und dann hatten wir diese
lehrer die an gar nicht geglaubt haben
die sind dann nochmal so umgegangen
haben überall geguckt
ja und dann würde ich heute meistens
erwischt dann gab es für mich nicht ein
strich sondern zwei striche weil ich
auch gelogen habe weil das würde ich
auch so also regelmäßigkeit vollkommen
okay ich finde man kann ja mal die
hausaufgaben ausfallen lassen in den
phasen des unterrichts 20 stets
arbeitsbereit insgesamt kann es so
weitergehen
superstar sondern schauen wir mal wie
sie hier in chemie biochemie war
wirklich mein absolutes hast und ich
habe da nichts verstanden ja im verlauf
der epoche fand chantal zugang zur
chemischen relevanten sachverhalten und
konnte in einzelnen beiträgen fachlich
kompetent auskunft geben
so erwarte sich bis zur klassenarbeit
fachkenntnisse dir zu einem befriedigen
des ausreichend ergebnis verhalfen
befriedigend bis ausreichend voll okay
ausreichend reicht aus ihre
zuverlässigen geführten epochen hälfte
überzeugten durch inhaltliche klar
strukturierte aufschrieb sowie
übersichtliche skizzen ja die epochen
hefte sind echt wichtig ich weiß nicht
also ohne epochen hälfte dann kommt man
als spieler wirklich nicht voran
das ist das kochen hilft vielleicht so
etwas wie ein hausaufgabenheft oder also
insgesamt eine gelungene leistung mit
befriedigendem niveau machen wir weitere
biologie jetzt sehe ich sogar den namen
aber ich bin ja so nett weil das
wahrscheinlich nicht möchtest dass man
den namen hier lesen kann bzw
nur beim vornamen zu sehen auch wenn
chantal einem privatgespräch nie
abgeneigt ist so glänzt die dann auch
durch wache und reflektierte beiträge
die ihr interesse am fach widerspiegeln
ihre hausaufgaben erledigt sie
zuverlässig und im schriftlichen
etwas unter dem schriftlichen test
erzielte sie ein hervorragendes ergebnis
ein epochen heft hat sie nicht abgegeben
wie du führst dein epochen f was auch
immer das ist in chemie hervorragend und
gibt es in biologie nicht mal insgesamt
bewegen sich schon teils leistungen im
sehr guten bereich ok und jetzt kommt
die beste aussage liebe stand halt lasst
die jungs um dich herum reden und
konzentriere dich auf den unterricht du
hast ein gutes verständnis für
biologische zusammenhänge weiter soja an
die bio lehrerin das ist natürlich so
dass man das als lehrerin so sieht aber
ich kann schon verstehen dass sich schon
teil auch auf die jungs konzentriert
stellt euch mal vor auf chantal zweite
schule sind wirklich junge spieler die
so aussehen und um stadtteil umsätzen im
biologieunterricht war natürlich nur
spaß kommen wir zustand als nächstem
spezialfach und zwar hat jeder andere
auch in der schule gartenbau also die
haben gerade ein bestandteil kamen stets
gut gelaunt freudig und immer motiviert
und unterricht die theoretischen
einheiten gefielen ihr nicht immer sie
konnte sich aber darauf einlassen und
machte gut in der gruppe mit bei den
praktischen aufgaben gefielen ihr alle
sie gingen vorurteilsfrei auf diese zu
und setzen die anweisung sorgfältig
zuverlässig und ausbauen um der leute
das ist doch perfekt stellt euch mal vor
ihr lehrer in der schule liege später
euren garten baut die zweite schule
heute praktische aufgabe zaun bauen
beete umgraben ist so geil ich meine
würde ich auch nicht mehr machen als
mathe lernen und dann kommt ihr hier
noch zu den letzten fächern euro ein
uneingeschränktes lob für stadtteil in
diesem neuen schuljahr außer wenn sie
einmal wieder ein schwätzchen halten
musste ich laut die bubble ganz schön
viel zumindest steht in jeder bewertung
drin dass sie sich nicht ablenken soll
dass sie nicht so viel lagern soll dass
sie sich nicht von den jungs abdrängen
lassen soll
mit großem engagement arbeitete sie in
allen stunden an allen gestellten
aufgaben und der freude so oft der blick
auf sie fiel viele geometrische
verwandlung formen dynamische über und
natürlich unsere zentral gearbeitet ich
kann das ich lese das ist so
und irgendwie auch wenn die stücke
bewegten sie in jeder beziehung
hervorragend leicht und sehr musikalisch
ja und bei sport zu beginn des
schuljahres beschäftigten sich die
schüler mit dem erarbeiten das mit witz
und vielen ideen schritt schon teil
hierbei ans werk im unterricht begegnete
man ihr freundlich und motiviert sie
stellte sich den unterschiedlichen
anforderungen tauchte in längere phase 1
verbesserte einzelne technische
ausführung mit dem ball und war somit
gut in der lage ihre sportlichen
grundlagen zu verbessern
besonders die leichtathletischen
elemente waren bestandteil mit
leichtigkeit zu nehmen einzelne
korrekturen umzusetzen oder ein gutes
resultat zu erzielen
die beiden mattenbach so genau das fach
sport das hatte ich auch schon in meinem
letzten video davon ja leute also so
kann ein waldorfschulen zeugnis aussehen
ich bin jetzt auch um eine information
reicher wenn es noch nicht gesehen hat
sollte auf jeden fall dass viele vom
gästen abzusagen oder irgendein anderes
keine ahnung aber ich habe dazu jetzt
schon 34 video das auf jeden fall noch
nach oben da ich würde sagen bei 8006
gibt es das nächste zeugnis video video
video dazu zeugnis video video dazu
könnt ihr auf jeden fall auf instagram
oder auch snatchers ich glaube es ist
hier und ernst aber muss hier und wir
sehen uns sonntag spätestens wieder rein